nous avons tous des ennuis avec le
stationnement qu'on habite Paris ou la
province il y a les aubergines or
Stéphane Collaro
Stéphane Collaro que l'on connaît mal on
connaît l'aspect qui apparaît à la
télévision Stéphane Collaro est un homme
qui a voué sa vie entière à la défense
de l'automobile et lorsque dans quelques
années je prononcerai son éloge funèbre
vu la couleur que j'ai ça va peut-être
plutôt
je dirais Stéphane Collaro vous avez
beaucoup fait pour les autres vive la
France vive la voiture à bas les
contraventions voilà comment
si si vous avez la chance de mourir
avant moi j'en ferai autant pour vous et
bah écoutez alors là vraiment écoutez le
premier qui meurt invite l'autre à dîner
d'accord avec plaisir merci pour cette
invitation
niveau non plus Stéphane Collaro pour la
première fois de votre vie
sérieusement j'aimerais que vous vous
montriez aux téléspectateurs tel que
vous êtes dans la réalité bah c'est
difficile aujourd'hui si c'est pas bon
bref tous les jours devant l'Empire j'ai
environ deux ou trois contraventions à
50 francs ça sent celle de vendredi et
avec un
monsieur qui est un savant un savant qui
a renoncé à la science s'appelle le
docteur poupouze un homme curieux mais
c'est un savant très très important car
il consacre où il est né oui il est né
dans le sud-ouest de la France il est né
à Pamiers c'est vrai c'est le docteur
Poupousse Pamiers
oui c'est vrai
parfaitement
enfin bref ce docteur est moins en fondé
un laboratoire ou des étudiants depuis
plusieurs mois des solutions pour éviter
ces contraventions car 150 francs pour
un stationnement interdit c'est quand
même beaucoup et nous avons déjà proposé
plusieurs solutions en voici une
nouvelle qui je le pense choses
intéressés elle vient vraiment de naître
à l'instant les nez cette semaine je
vous signale que le document que vous
allez voir a été réalisé en direct vous
allez le voir dans toute son
authenticité donc le nouveau dispositif
anti-contraventions que nous avons
imaginé avec le diabolique docteur
Poupousse un dispositif simple mais
terriblement efficace sur le toit de
notre voiture une galerie et sur cette
galerie des morceaux de carton mais
attention pas n'importe quel morceau de
carton vous garez votre voiture devant
un parcmètre jusqu'ici rien d'anormal
mais là là le carton va intervenir et
regardez de quelle manière
défaite les Sando
et vous rabattez les panneaux de carton
un panneau devant la voiture
un panneau derrière la voiture
un panneau de chaque côté
ces morceaux de carton commence à
prendre tournure une tournure familière
regardez le dernier panneau se rabat et
vous avez non plus une voiture mais une
caisse en carton
[Musique]
pour parfaire le tout quelques morceaux
de papier collant à chaque coin
et les bien évidemment qu'il va devenir
parfaitement inutile de mettre une pièce
dans le darkmètre puisque ce n'est plus
une voiture qui est garée là mais une
caisse en carton toute bête vous partez
tranquillement travailler et vous attend
vers 10h la contractuelle tasse elle
fait son travail c'est bien normal elle
a raison bravo el verbalisent des
voitures qui gênent la circulation c'est
honteux mais elle passe devant votre
caisse en carton sans rien remarquer la
normale pourquoi mettrait-elle une
contravention à une caisse en carton ce
serait stupide vous êtes en train de
travailler bien tranquillement pendant
ce temps-là et vers midi la
contractuelle repasse et bien évidemment
qu'elle n'a aucune raison de verbaliser
une caisse en carton d'abord une caisse
en carton n'a pas numéro
d'immatriculation par contre la voiture
qui est derrière mérite un papillon
c'est tout à fait normal bravo Madame
vous faites votre devoir
3 heures nouvelle apparition de la
contractuel la cassera carton de risque
absolument rien et elle continue à
verbaliser à l'entour vers 17h elle
passe à deux cette fois et tous ceux qui
n'ont pas mis leurs pièces en prennent
plein la figure sauf vous bien sûr c'est
normal une caisse en carton
vers 19h vous n'avez plus qu'à quitter
votre travail sans avoir à quitter le
moindre franc de parking vous rabattez
vos panneaux et vous trouvez votre
voiture vierge de toute contravention et
également de toute poussière
voilà un système très simple qui devrait
vous permettre d'économiser 3 contre
inventions à 50 francs par jour soit 150
francs si on compte qu'il y a environ
une vingtaine de jours ouvrables dans le
mois ça peut représenter jusqu'à 3000
francs décodenis par mois bravo docteur
poupon
[Musique]